welcome back to new rockstars i'm your
host for the day sam bash and i've
returned to review the next installment
of the marvel cinematic universe phase
one films
thor yay released in 2011 this was
marvel's first dabble with the cosmic
side of their cinematic playground and
i'm gonna be honest
it doesn't hold up i'm sorry i don't
mean to be a bummer but it doesn't but
anyways today i'm not here to review the
film i'm here to point out every single
easter egg hidden reference that i could
possibly find for your enjoyment
what did director kenneth branagh and
the marvel team hide in this film oh
we're just gonna have to wait and see
but first here's your spoiler warning
for the thor trilogy weird that we've
made it through three of those films
the thor comics the mcu in general and
everything else in the universe just to
be safe let's begin with our favorite
easter eggs
excuse me my favorite easter eggs comic
book teasers and to kick that off here's
odin growling loki for some reason
the best part of the movie i audibly
laughed so loud my roommates had to come
and ask what i was watching first up
thor the name of the movie our main
character his first appearance in marvel
comics was in journey into mystery
number 83
in 1962. he's very similar to his norse
counterpart in a way if not really at
all except for the hammer even the
hammer is a little bit different don't
worry i'll get to that in just a little
bit but in the comics originally he was
human
going by the name donald blake little
spoilers we'll get to him in a little
bit donald found himself a little stick
that when he bang it on the ground he
turned into the god of thunder himself
with the hammer and everything he
actually got to tease this in ragnarok
again i'm getting ahead of myself
very excited but something very exciting
you get the actual thor
accurate comic costume right here in his
debut appearance in the film
oh boy i'm a big fan of that little
helmet but i understand why it never
showed up again it looks heavy as hell
agl huh little four joke but the first
character we actually meet in this film
is
jane foster oh she plays a big part in
the comics her first appearance though
was in journey into mystery number 84
just after thor's appearance and she's
been a love interest and maybe sometimes
a hero and now currently in the comics
she's thor and honestly i'm a big fan
of jane foster thor i think she's really
cool i think her story is really
interesting
and natalie portman playing jane foster
wasn't amazing but wasn't awful let's be
fair to her guys come on and then we
meet mr eric self excuse me
dr eric selvik let's show some respect
originally he was created for just this
movie but he was added
into the main marvel comic universe
during avengers standoff it was at an
event a few years ago and then he was
promptly
killed off oops then we get our awesome
backstory very transformers-esque here
it makes sense because it was made by
paramount the same company that makes
transformers we meet king
laufey and originally he is in north
mythology but his comic book
counterpart is more true to this movie
so let's focus on him his original
appearance was in journey into mystery
number 112
in 1965 and same with all the frost
giants as well
they are a little bit different from the
mythology version of the frost giants
but the you know they did a pretty good
job of adapting the comic book version
of them into this movie we also see
jotenheim or jotenheim is yotenham
that's how you're supposed to pronounce
it home of the frost giants being one of
the three realms we visit in this movie
the other two being asgard the home of
the asgardians thank you so much
also midgard which is earth very cool
the other six realms being
bear with me i tried my best i am not
going to pronounce these great but i'm
going to do my best here we go
first up muselfind which is the home of
surtur alphaheim which is the home of
the lighthouse
which we haven't really met in these
movies vanaheim which there's not too
much info on there
nymphalheim home of hella which is hell
then
swertelheim home of the dark elves you
can go ahead and kill me in the comments
about that one that's where malachite
comes from
and then nidovir home of the dwarves oh
boy i butchered those but you can just
read them on the screen just don't hate
me too much i try my best i'm trying to
teach you guys something but next up
let's give a shout out to odin whose
first appearance in marvel comics was
journey into mystery number 85
in 1962. i love the headpiece they
choose to use form it's very similar to
his north mythology look which sometimes
you know rams heads or you know get the
antlers also worth mentioning his spear
gun guinea is
very cool in this movie i like the way
it was used but more on that a little
bit we're then introduced to friega
thor's mother in the comics but actually
mythology it's more of his stepmother
but anyways let's focus on the comic
book part your favorite part her first
appearance was in journey into mystery
number 92
in 1963. she doesn't get too much to do
in this movie but everybody loves renee
russo so give her some love in the
comments
next we meet sif who in mythology is
actually thor's wife
eventually but in the comics she's
usually just his friend her first
appearance was in journey into mystery
number 102 in 1964 we even get to see
some of her awesome sword action when
they're on
yotenheim fighting the frost giants it's
very cool we then meet the warriors
three who are original creations for the
thor
comics they're actually not in the
mythology whatsoever but
we should still give them some love we
see fandral played by josh dallas only
in this movie though zachary levi takes
over that role in the next two movies
but i'm getting ahead of myself also
when they're fighting the frost giants
you see his signature weapon the little
sword big fan of that we also see hogan
played by tatanabu asano he has his mace
which is always
so cool also he gets a very cool fight
in ragnarok which i'm very excited to
talk about later and then we have
volstag played by
ray stevenson who also played the
punisher in that weird punisher sequel
that most people didn't watch but it is
very violent if you're into that also we
get to see him
using his axe and we still get a joke
there were a few scenes of volstead cut
in this movie but we still get a scene
of him eating a bunch because this is
what he looks like
in the comics he's got me and then we
meet everyone's favorite villain
loki you get him in his signature helmet
as well and fun fact in mythology he's
not
really a villain he's just a trickster
but in the comics of course
he is a big old villain and his first
appearance was in journey into mystery
number 85. you notice i've said journey
into mystery many times don't worry it's
going to come back
in a very cool way to stick with me it's
very cool you see a signature small
daggers you get this snake imagery right
here which they joked about
in ragnarok his use of projections is
always going to be cool which we see
again in avengers and many other movies
and you also see him
suggesting selvik at the very end of the
film now that never comes back again
in the movies but that is from the
comics which is very cool next we get to
see the
weapons vault of asgard which is very
cool and there are a lot of easter eggs
hidden here so bear with me because
there's some cool stuff i'm about to
mention for you first up
mjolnir uh we gotta of course mention
thor's signature hammer because there's
a lot of fun
easter eggs on the hammer which i think
you guys probably missed but let's talk
about its origins in the movie they
mentioned that it was
crafted inside of a dying star which is
not in mythology or actually in the
comics either actually in the comics the
origin was that it was crafted by the
dwarves out of uru which is this really
strong material but recently they kind
of changed a little bit to be this
housing
for an evil sentient lightning storm
that was destroying the universe i kind
of like that one i'm going to be honest
but
whatever you guys like let me know your
favorite origin in the comments down
below we then see the eternal flame
which belonged to searcher which was
stolen by odin then brought back to the
vault anyways you can check all this out
in our ragnarok breakdown on this
channel next we see the casket of
ancient winters which is one of the
mcguffins
of this thor film this actually does pop
up in the thor
comics actually during the ragnarok
event is what actually comes before
ragnarok they use it to freeze over the
entire realm it's very scary then we get
into the stuff that we don't
quite recognize let's focus on this eye
first up this has never been confirmed
but for the most part
most fans have figured out that this is
warlock's eye which is a weapon of
harrow kin
one of thor's villains back in the day
and then we get this orb in the
background which again has not been
confirmed but most people are able to
figure out that this
might be the org of agamotto it's a blue
orb and it might be a piece of the magic
that doctor strange could use in the
future but since ragnarok kind of blew
up all of asgard
don't know if we can really get our
hands on that anymore but my favorite
little easter egg
is this piece of rock right here now
there's a few theories is what this
could be but
for the most part it's going to be a
tablet of some kind some people have
thought that it's maybe the tablet of
life which you know
brings life or bestows power onto people
or the table of death which you know
kills people or of chaos and order which
will be a fun nod to the cosmic side of
marvel but again
who knows since it all blew up oh and
don't worry guys i'm never gonna miss
this one
we do get a hint of the infinity
gauntlet with all the infinity gems in
the background for just a second
even watching this film i still miss
this i had to rewind it a couple times
to find this little hint but eventually
in ragnarok they prove that this is fake
so it doesn't really hold any water but
moving on the frost giant sneaking into
the vault actually this was replicated
most recently in the marvel legacy event
so it doesn't really have any
you know bearing on this movie i just
found that the comics recreated the
scene from the first thor movie we then
get the crowning of
thor as king of asgard which does happen
in the comics sometimes in the future
author jason aaron actually wrote a very
cool run where current thor
teams up with future king thor and past
you know adolescent thor it's a very
good one i highly recommend you check it
out but moving forward we then meet the
destroyer
he's the main baddish weapon man of this
movie oh no
he actually doesn't appear in any of the
mythology shocker but he did make his
first appearance in marvel comics and
journey into mystery number 118
doing the same thing he does in this
movie fight thor we then meet everyone's
favorite character heimdall played by
idris elba from the comics and he is
also in mythology as the gatekeeper of
the bifrost his first comic appearance
was in journey into mystery number 85.
man i kind of wish he showed up more in
the avengers films but might be too late
but speaking of the bifrost
this is also in mythology and in the
comics this is actually the rainbow
bridge that helped asgardians
get to earth and back and forth and so
on but in the comics they use it as just
a general transportation to anywhere in
the nine realms and also it's worth
mentioning
one very sleuthy internet person was
able to figure out that this
writing here on thor's hammer actually
ties it back to
the comic version of mjolnir now in the
comics on mjolnir it's written whosoever
holds this
hammer if he be worthy shall possess the
power of thor
in the movie if you actually read around
the top of the hammer it
reads when translated he who holds this
hammer commands the lightning and the
storm that's a very fun easter egg thank
you so much
nice internet person then scooting
forward again to the hammer falling to
earth this crater that the hammer's in
it kind of seems similar to the civil
war comics that everyone's a big fan of
over at marvel
originally the hammer just crash landed
in the middle of america and then
somebody else picks it up i don't want
to spoil civil war if you guys want to
go read it it's a very crazy comic but
then scooting forward coming back to pay
off that journey into mystery line that
i repeated over and over again if you
check this poster
in this town that thor and jane foster
the whole crew are hanging out in you'll
see this little advertisement reading
land of enchantment journey into mystery
ah that's the first appearance of thor
cool it comes back round very cool then
scooting forward to win thor's trying on
his mortal clothes you'll see this name
tag suck to him it's a very obvious
easter egg
to donald like the name i mentioned
earlier as the man who originally took
up the mantle of thor
in the comics actually it's pretty fun
to mention that donald blake originally
was a human that could transform
into the god thor and then it that was
kind of retconned that donald blake
was thor very cool and he had just lost
his memory because odin was trying to
teach him a lesson
sound familiar yes it's the plot of this
entire film then scooting forward to
odin resting
recharging well actually this is the
odin sleep which they mentioned in the
movie
but in the comics this is a device that
is used to recharge
the odin force within odin it's a
magical force that he named himself that
gives him his power the odin force
anyways moving forward to an avengers
tease check out this clip
[Music]
he's so dumb that he reaches for a gun
and then reaches for the bow and arrow
but hey
hawkeye his very first appearance in the
mcu fun fact he actually doesn't appear
with
thor in his first appearance he appears
in tales of suspense number 57
originally as a villain and then as his
little redemption arc when he becomes a
part of the avengers with scarlet witch
quicksilver and captain america but hey
he does look very spooky in this he
looks kind of like a villain in this now
i did want to mention thor being
unworthy of the hammer is actually a
very big plot point of his current comic
run of odin's son not jane foster ass
thor but actual odinson's walking around
with a giant axe and he's not able to
pick up the hammer anymore
what could that mean just go read the
comics it's very cool but again this has
happened many different times in the
comics i'm just saying the current one
is very interesting now let's move
forward to thor
teaching jane about yidracel the world
tree which is the mythological tree that
connects all the nine realms in the
cosmos i love the visualization of this
tree in this movie because you can kind
of see it
built together out of all the
constellations and the cosmos and the
different gaseous bodies out there in
space it's one of the most beautiful
parts of this movie but then switching
forward to the end credits scene we get
the tease of nick fury and eric selvig
talking looking at this cosmic cube
or the tesseract and you see loki
suggesting things to salvage and get
involved with this
project project you say well in avengers
we actually find out that this facility
is project pegasus which in the comics
is a facility they use to actually
monitor the multiverse to travel to
other universes which is very fun it's a
bummer that spoilers and avengers this
entire facility blows up but it does
make sense since the tesseract ends up
being the space stone which
opens portals to other places in space
for traveling it's not the same but hey
we're pretty close but before we knew
this was a test tesseract or a space
dome hiding as a tesseract we all
thought this was a cosmic cube which is
a big part of marvel comics and it
actually made its first appearance in
tales of suspense number 89
and it was a wish granting cube it could
alter reality and make anything you'd
want ooh
very cool now moving on to mcu easter
egg starting with the marvel logo i
really missed this flip book i know
all of the ones we've gotten after this
are still pretty cool but this one just
has a special place in my heart also
notice all the dutch angles in this film
because if you watch the after credits
scene in iron man 2 which was
shot by the director of thor kenneth
branagh he has the same dutch angles in
it there's just a few too many in here
i'm going to be honest
it's a little much then scooting forward
to our flashback once again you see that
this town in norway is homesburg trying
my best to
pronounce that correctly this is
actually the same town that appears in
captain america when the red skull goes
looking for the tesseract very cool but
again we'll talk about that
next week also it's worth mentioning
that odin seems to lost the same eye
that thor did in ragnarok
very cool then moving forward again to
thor almost becoming king
notice that this is the throne room the
same throne that we see in the other two
thor movies and that's always inside of
a giant hall
but here it's totally outside like 100
so
something must have changed somebody
didn't agree with somebody so they'd
make it inside
you also get a very big tease of the
bifrost being the main weapon of this
movie when uh heimdall is explaining
what the bifrost can do
right here leave the bridge open would
unleash the full power of the bifrost
and destroy you tonheim with you
upon it also i want to point something
out in the incredible hulk and in iron
man 2 you get these shots of soldiers
firing gatling guns into like living
areas for people like apartment
buildings or giant crowds and you're
just like oh that's kind of cool but
aren't people dying
same thing here when thor does that
giant lightning strike it's an awesome
moment but then just
thousands upon thousands of frost giants
are dying i know they're the bad guys
but it's just like you start to question
it when you age up just a little bit but
anyways here's my favorite part of the
movie right here
odin growling at loki is the best part
of almost any marvel movie i could
possibly think of i know
it's so stupid but i don't care moving
on ooh here's that colson shot we got
from iron man 2 saying yes sir we found
it but also make sure you keep an eye on
all of these random people who are
trying to lift thor's hammer i'll come
back to them in just a little bit here's
the easter eggs you want you hear
selving say this right
here i knew the scientist the pioneer in
gamma radiation
oh pioneer and gamma radiation he's
obviously mentioning bruce banner or
betty ross who are working on a gamma
radiation project
just a little bit before this movie
takes place then moving on to the shield
base i want to give a shout out to this
actor right here he's made an appearance
and many devon marvel properties
specifically winter soldier and agents
of shield tv show
this is sitwell actually i'm a big fan
of him because in the comics he ends up
dying kind of like he does
in captain america winter soldier but
then he comes back as a zombie yeah
coming to the end of the movie we get a
hint to these secret paths between
worlds right here
there are secret paths between the
worlds to which even you with all your
gifts are blind
of course they probably had to add this
or maybe it was already in the script
but so that it made sense why thor could
come to earth for the avengers film
it just works you know but really quick
guys to end this video i wanted to point
out some fun pop culture references that
i was able to catch when i was watching
this movie like how the intro i
mentioned this before has a transformers
feel to it i'll play some optimus
opening dialogue some
wanted it for good others for evil
odin's opening dialogue from a realm of
cold and darkness
came the frost giants it's both made by
paramount so it kind of makes sense that
they were like you need this the same
kind of inflection but moving forward
look at this guy who's trying to pick up
the hammer he's in the red truck he
seems important right the camera's
spending way too much time on him
usually in movies and tv shows that
means they're important because this man
is j michael strzinski who is a writer
over at marvel specifically for
thor in spider-man he's also very famous
so i was very excited to see him in this
movie and then we see
the man himself walt simonson the
creator of beta ray bill
throg everything you love about thor
he's sitting at the table
right here check him out and finally
guys the last two little bits i'm going
to leave you with is of course the
stanley cameo he's the one trying to use
his truck to pull milner out of the
crater it don't work and finally i want
to say
this movie has the best thor wig of
every other thor wig we've seen in
every other marvel movie i mean
sometimes it looks real rough and this
it works but hey guys i hope you enjoyed
this video let me know which of these
was your favorite little easter egg let
me know what i possibly missed you can
follow me on twitter at sambashore at
only stupid answers and get those vowels
from stupid make sure you like this
video
comment down below share with your
friends and subscribe for more
breakdowns make sure you check out new
rockstars news every weekend we talk
about all the up-to-date and current
nerdy news i know you guys are a big fan
of that and i'll see you guys
next time
you